in the lobby of Ramsey solutions alex is
with us hey Alex how are you I'm good
how are you better than I deserve
welcome welcome where are you from from
Atlanta well thank you thank you for
driving up from Atlanta merry Christmas
to you as well and here to do your
debt-free scream yes sir I love it
congratulations thank you how much debt
have you paid off just over a hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars
Wow and how long did that take you hmm
eight months okay all right and what was
your household income during that time I
started at 32,000 and now I'm right at
60,000 okay obviously those numbers
don't add up what kind of debt was that
I'm a little bit of student loan a
little bit on a truck and my mortgage
paid off the house and everything okay
so eight months ago you started a
journey tell me the story
sorry um well back the story up a little
bit from the eight months that that's
okay sure in her story in December of
2013 my boyfriend at the time was
diagnosed with a terminal cancer oh yes
and in January of 2014 we got engaged
May of 2014 we got married he went
through chemo radiation treatment was in
remission of no in November of last year
there at this time I was working
overnights commuting an hour to go to
the University of Georgia to finish my
degree and listening to your show as I
drove back and forth
what was it what's your degree in
management information systems I'm a
technology consultant okay so when Jesse
was in remission of last year in
November I decided for Christmas I would
ask for your book and he and I were
going to get on the plan and we were
gonna do this life was good it was on
the upswing to receive the book for
Christmas and January of this year his
cancer came back and February 5th of
this year he passed away thankfully
32 so you were married 18 months no we
were married nine months
oh not much you've been okay we've been
together before that correct
and so I am a at the time 26 year old
widow with proceeds from a life
insurance policy more money at once than
I've ever had in my life and wanted to
make wise decisions with it he had life
insurance how he later
were you even dating them correct
through work Oh through work okay okay
we couldn't get a policy once we were
married because of the diagnosis so I
stopped for some time had the money and
wanted to to make him proud and make
wise decisions with it and got
counseling and advice and talked to a
financial advisor this is what I want to
do am I thinking about this in the right
way and got the go-ahead and the
thumbs-up and the yes yes you are
and so I I wrote the checks and I paid
off his truck and paid off my student
loans and paid off paid off our home and
my journey maybe not as long as some
people who have come here and shared
their stories and you know not digging
down deep like some people have but if I
can step on it on a on a soapbox for
just a moment and talk to the people
that are my age the the newlyweds in
their twenties that life is good and
life is exciting and yes it is but
you're not invincible and take care of
your loved ones so so you newlyweds get
your wills in place and get your life
insurance in place while you're healthy
I know it's not funny to talk about or
it's not fun to talk about death when
you're in your 20s or in your third user
or ever for that matter but but these
things happen so take take our story as
the the nudge the encouragement you know
what have you that have fun enjoy your
life sure but also also get your your
things in order what kind of cancer did
he have he had multiple myeloma which is
a blood cancer typically diagnosed in 60
and 70 and 80 year old patients he had
no family history of it healthy guy you
know law enforcement he was the rancor
all of that was he serving at the time
he was a reservist
working full-time job and then and then
you know in the reserves as well okay
was that where the insurance was or the
full-time full-time okay and I don't
know what to ask I'm just dumbfounded I
mean that you can stand up here and do
this is your level of poise is just
absolutely amazing thank you it's um
it's not easy it's it's easier to talk
about now than it was in February or in
March or in April absolutely but but not
easy by any means I would take all the
debt back - oh yeah have him here but
he's not in the mood and that's okay you
know my prayer when it came back was you
know God if you're gonna take this away
from him take it away from him please if
not take him quickly don't let him
suffer and and so that's okay I can have
peace you know with that knowing that
he's not suffering it was real quick the
second time correct yes sir Wow amazing
and so you're 27 now I'll be 27 on
Sunday Wow well happy birthday
thank you Wow well it's a great reminder
for everybody listening to make sure
they get their wheels in place and and
get life insurance in place because you
just don't know you just don't know and
so obviously you're all spiritual life
was healthy yes yes it was
yeah a place you know between between
that between our faith between you know
prayers from us and family and friends
and all of that and then the support of
family and friends it was it made a
really difficult situation that much or
a little bit easier you know yeah I
don't know how people deal with it but
don't
I wouldn't wish it on anybody but it's
okay and so you're back at work I'm back
at work living life yep so I graduated
school in May um started my new job in
July and I'm actually working on a
client here in Nashville so I was up
here working this week and then spending
the day here with y'all so life is
headed in in a in a good direction all
things considered
absolutely absolutely considering that
February is when all that went down yeah
so the whole story is less than two
years yes from then till now well about
well from this is 2015 December's only
13 December the two year story Wow
that's quick yes you crammed a lot of
life into two years a lot of life a lot
of learning a lot of emotion a lot of
it's been a roller coaster that's that's
my description for it yeah well I'm
proud of you obviously a brave young
woman amazingly poised I'm I mean I'm
not sure I'm gonna get through sitting
saying or talking to you and you're
doing better not you so it's amazing Wow
well it's not the way we want to end up
debt-free that's for sure but it is the
result if you go through this that you
do one a half it's where you want to be
which is what your your your soapbox is
about it's about make sure you have the
life insurance in place make sure you
have the wheel in place because you're
standing here right now feeling very
loved yeah as a result and you're
financially set unable to go a whole lot
of directions from here and you know the
healing process that you go through is
is completely different than if you were
completely broke right now and had
medical bills piled up around you
exactly so very very good man serving
his country and his wife is taken care
of and life is you know we salute him
right now for sure what was his name
again Jesse Jesse Jesse
Staff Sergeant Jesse Sousa Alex and
Jesse from Atlanta Georgia
a hundred and seventy-five thousand
dollars paid off in eight months making
thirty two to sixty thousand a year
counted down Alex let's hear a debt free
scream all right just this one's for you
three two one I'm debt free
Wow Wow Wow well you just don't get that
on talk radio when you do hear because
life happens here on this show to remind
us how to live our lives better every
day thank you Alex
absolutely amazing this is the Dave
Ramsey show you guys would be so rich so
fast and be able to do so much not only
for yourselves and for your family but
for others